but LeBron was cool because he didn't
have to say what's up but he saw me he's
like yo pulled up and we talked for like
a minute what was cool and it was just
like I just I don't follow basketball
but I follow greatness some people are
full on just like yo you're great at
what you do yeah so talking to him was
yeah it was a cool moment I think that
the reason why it's so easy to give it
up for a fighter is because there's no
ego involved for a not fighter how so
I know you me up so I could just
say you're great but for a basketball
player to basketball player it's like
bust your ass one-on-one
they're still like a little bit maybe
for an actor an actor or comedian
comedian a Musician musician like
fighter hotels I've been yeah I know you
see how fighter fighter goes it's like
almost a fight every single time